The greatest common factor for 15, 20 and -35 is just 5. That's going to start
the product for my GCF. Now I want to lowest factor for f that is common between
all the terms. Well, just 1 x is common between all the terms. The lowest power
of Y that is common is 2. So y squared would also appear in my GCF. An finally,
I look at the lowest power of Z between all of the terms, but I have to be
careful. There's no z over here. So z won't be included in my GCF. So a factor
of 5x y squared from each of these terms. I need 3x y squared z cubed for the
first term. 4z to the fifth of the second term and negative x squared y for the
last term. I can do this pretty quickly if just check the multiplication as I
go. 5 times 3 is 15. X times x is x squared, and y squared times y squared is y
to the 4th. Of course, I also have this z cubed on the end. So this is my first
term. When I multiply these two terms together, I get 20xy squared z to the
fifth. The variables are just listed are multiplied together. And 5 times 4 is
20. Finally, I know this last term must be correct. 5 times negative 7 is
negative 35, and x times x squared is x cubed. The last variable is y cubed,
which comes from y squared times y. So yeah, this is definitely my factored
form.